comme le murmurent d'un souvenir
provenant des plantations de canne les
vibrations du bob de stéphane grondin
nous relie à un passé pas si lointain
celui où la musique et les traditions se
mêler au gré des saisons et des
revendications
comment la traditionnelle aux mondiaux
ap les vieilles au sort mais quand on
fait venir une tête j'ai pu donner un
petit coup de neuf à la tradition ce mal
au gala c'est au mas et r rooney un bel
hommage tout ce que le maloya la
patinoire pendant ces 25 des années un
quart de siècle disait le momment pour
chanter d'anciens malo via tantôt festif
tantôt aux revendications
[Musique]
et là même où la patrie
avec la disco vider les annulations des
manifestations des fèves des concerts
stéphane grondin ils voient une atteinte
à l'identité réunionnaise grands
festivals animations de quartier qu'ont
fait plus rien ou détruit le lien social
ici ou là ou détruit le lien social et
j'ai rompu aux ordres de ses coûts
depuis la musique jeunes après un moment
d'évasion scène après un moment de
conscientisation aussi de certaines
choses aussi parce qu'une fois une bonne
sortie s'il vient me chante pour fait
danser mais n'appuie chante aussi pour
se comprendre certaines choses et faits
de société
mamie pense que cette crise là là là
assassiné le milieu culturel à la
réunion réaliste mais optimiste il
estime que chacun peut et devrait à son
échelle pour perpétuer l'esprit du
maloya est là donc ceci c'est un
exutoire aussi permettent aussi d des
foulées des vraiment vidé le corps et
l'esprit de tous que nana en charge
négative dans notre corps et c'est ça
qui est pour moi le malg à la danse les
indissociables du maloya et la bleue
fait il devait pas bouger bien épais
belle danse comme dean est comme qui
dirait d'un pays à six y mettre les
pieds dans le pied deux doigts de pieds
dans ce ciel on a envie de bouger mais
il est pas bouger mais ne peut dire nous
québec
après la pluie le beau temps de
m'asseoir et juin meilleur faux
d'espérer l'espoir d'une sortie du chaos
tumultueux de la crise pour retrouver le
son harmonieux puiser dans le
savoir-faire de ses aïeux inspiré par
des valeurs fortes simplicité
ingéniosité et volonté
[Musique]